yeah your father's house
just a busted
the bastard of Robert of the house
Baratheon first of his name king of the
Andals in the first man why do you think
the gold cloaks wanted you the realm do
you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video today I want to talk
about everyone's favorite blacksmith Ken
jury as we all know ginjury went missing
from the show for several seasons but
now that they brought him back what
purpose could he possibly serve to the
story I would like to think they brought
this character back for a good reason
but what could that be before we get
started I just want to give a quick
reminder about the new giveaway the
author of A Song of Ice and Fire
released a new book about the history of
House Targaryen in that book is called
fire and blood I bought one extra copy
that way I could give one away if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win a copy of fire and blood just click
on the link that is down below good luck
everyone
now let's get started like I said today
I want to talk about ginjury and a few
different reasons why I think they may
have brought this character back into
the main plot of the story in my opinion
or at least I hope so I think they kept
this character alive for all these years
for a very good reason but why did they
bring him back now
since grand jury has been able to escape
death so many times it makes me think he
does have a part to play in the eighth
and final season in Game of Thrones
let's just go over a few of the times
that ginjury was actually able to avoid
death typically when a character is able
to do this over and over again it's
because they are saving him for a
specific purpose later on in the story
the crazy thing is people have been
trying to kill ginjury ever since the
first season after ginjuries father King
Robert Baratheon was killed Joffrey
rounded up all of Robert's bastards in
order to have them executed to get them
out of the way Gendry had to flee King's
Landing at the end of the first season
otherwise he would have been murdered as
well this was an aria in ginjury meat
for the first time as they begun their
long journey to the wall with urine from
the Nights Watch
thanks to urine he was able to get him
out of King's
landing before the city watch found him
but as we all know it did not take long
for them to find out where Gendry was at
the beginning of the second season the
gold cloaks were able to catch up to
urine and his recruits at the time aria
actually thought they were looking for
her but they had no reason to believe
Aria would be traveling to the wall with
the Nights Watch instead they were there
to get ginjury but thankfully urine
wasn't about to just hand him over to
the gold cloaks we're looking for a boy
named Gendry it carries a bull's head
helmet anyone turning him over will earn
the Kings reward we'll be back and I'll
be taking your head home along with that
fast
Gendry could not figure out why they
would want him so bad but he knew that
it couldn't be for anything good urine
was able to buy them some time but it
would not take long for them to return
once again but this time they were ready
to kill whoever stood in their way of
capturing King Robert's bastard ginjury
in sure enough they did return but this
time they were with Lannister men this
time they were out for blood but thanks
to arias quick wit she was able to
convince them that Lonnie was actually
injury because the bull headed helmet
was laying right next to the dead body
Gendry was able to escape death once
again but this time they were all taken
as prisoners to the cursed castle of
Harrenhal ginjury wasn't at Harrenhal
for very long before he almost died
again
Gendry was picked out of the crowd of
prisoners at random then he was striped
down in questioned by the man who has
known as the tickler just as Gendry was
about to get tortured Tywin Lannister
arrived and put a stop to this because
he knew the prisoners were better alive
than dead
Gendry was immediately put to work as a
blacksmith and as we all know Arya
became tywin lannister's cup bearer
shortly after this was when Jack and
agar offers to repay Arya for helping
him escape his own death
arya was able to save three men that
were locked inside of the card so jack
and offered to kill any three men that
she wanted this led to him helping ori
again jury and hot pie he escaped
Harrenhal in the middle of the night now
they were free at last but it would not
take long before ginjury was almost
killed again as they were making their
way through the woods they running
through the Brotherhood without banners
after spending some time
with them Gendry decided that he wanted
to make weapons for them and hopefully
become a member of the Brotherhood
that was until Melisandre showed up
Melisandre was looking for Gendry
because he has King's blood and this is
what Melisandre needed to perform her
sacrifice she wanted to do this in order
to help Stannis's cause so as you can
see before ginjury disappeared from the
show
he was constantly escaping death someone
was actively trying to kill him in every
season he appeared in but luckily he
always had someone else looking out for
him Melisandre was able to use some
again juries blood but before she could
fully sacrifice him Davos helped him
escape from Dragonstone after Davos
snuck him off the island we did not seek
injury from any seasons but why did they
bring him back now when you escaped
death that many times it makes me think
that you must have a bigger purpose or
else why Eve and bring him back what
would be the point unless he has a part
to play when you think about it again
jury is already a very important
character because as far as we know he
is the last living character with
Baratheon blood Brotherhood you told me
I could be one of you
you're more than they can ever be
they are just foot soldiers in the Great
Wall you will make Kings rise
all of the other Baratheon's are dead
which makes again jury the last of a
dying breed in order to keep house
Baratheon from going extinct they need
Gendry alive this may be one of the
reasons why they brought him back if you
look at the main logo for Game of
Thrones
it shows the four sigils from the four
major houses in the story House Stark
House Lannister House Targaryen and
house Baratheon ginjury is now the only
character left that can represent house
Baratheon which makes me think they will
continue to keep that character alive
even though Gendry did make his return
to the show in the seventh season he
could have been killed again when he
went out beyond the wall with John and
company they could have easily killed
ginjury during that mission but since
they kept him alive I am assuming he is
needed for a good reason in the final
season again jury maybe a bastard right
now but I have always thought that he
would be legitimized by the end of the
show they could have John or Daenerys do
this for him at the very end when and if
they finally have full control over
Westeros since ginjury is the last
character with Baratheon blood and the
Baratheon czar one of the four major
houses from the story
Gendry may end up with some lands and
titles of his own assuming he survives
the final battles obviously ginjuries
greatest asset is his ability to make
weapons he has been working with the
hammer ever since he was introduced and
he continued to hone that craft during
all the years that he went missing since
they brought him back right at the time
that John needs all of the weapons made
out of dragonglass I think it's safe to
assume again jury will have something to
do with that after all that was the main
reason why Davos went looking for him in
the first place he won again tree to go
straight to Winterfell and get started
right away but as we all know ginjury
opted out of that in exchange for
something more exciting
Gendry went out beyond the wall with Jon
and the other men but now that they
completed that mission I am guessing the
ginjury will now go to Winterfell to
serve his main purpose which is turning
all that dragonglass into weapons there
is also always that outside chance that
Gendry may learn how to work with
Valyrian steel as well now in the books
ginjuries mentor tompoma actually knows
how to reforge Valyrian steel in the
books he is the one who reforge his ice
into widows wail and Oathkeeper since
they decided to have a different
caracter do that in this show then
perhaps Kenzie knows nothing about
working with that type of metal but
Samwell Tarly did take a bunch of books
from the Citadel
not to mention brain star can always go
back in time and look at almost anything
that he wants so if Sam doesn't find the
methods in his books brain could always
go back and watch how Valyrian steel was
made then they could tell Gendry what to
do that's one possibility I mean why
else would you make Kendra a blacksmith
unless she wanted him to make some
special weapons of course another reason
why they may have brought ginjury back
was to make some kind of a marriage
alliance like I said in one of my recent
videos King Robert Baratheon always
wanted to join his house with Ned
Stark's house this is something he said
to Ned in the very first episode of the
show we were meant to rule together if
your sister had lived would have been
bound by blood well it's not too late I
have a son you have a daughter
when Robert said that to Ned he was
referring to Sansa and Joffrey getting
married but as we all know that never
happened however Robert's other son
ginjury could always marry one of the
stark daughters to join their houses
Arya would seem like the natural choice
since her and Gendry have already had a
very close relationship
but since Arya may never get married
perhaps sons and ginjury could get
married when and if he arrives at
Winterfell and they hit it off even if
none of these things happen I still
think n jury could have a very big part
to play in the end during the rebuilding
phase we all know that John and Danny
both want to make some drastic changes
to Westeros they need to make some
changes to the laws and the entire power
structure even if the Iron Throne is
destroyed and there is no longer one
king or queen running the Seven Kingdoms
I imagine there will be at least one
character alive from each of the major
houses together they may decide on how
Westeros will operate from here on out
after the battles with the knight King
in Cersei are over most of Westeros will
probably look like a battlefield castles
will get destroyed crops frozen over or
burnt and dead bodies littered across
all of the kingdoms among many other
things
so hopefully the right character is our
life standing at the end of
all of this that way spring isn't only a
dream thankfully Gendry is nothing like
Robert so if he does end up in a
position of power at the end you don't
have to worry about him doing the right
thing I can't really see ginjury
drinking or whoring his way into an
early grave like his dad did if
characters like ginjury Sam Davos John
or Danny are still alive at the end then
I think Westeros would be in good hands
but only time will tell
let me know why you think they brought
ginjury back what else do you think they
will have him do besides making weapons
put your thoughts down below in the
comment section anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching the video I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting the
channel I hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
you